ready to transform your next event into
a celebration well joining me now to
tell us how is carly turner owner of
celebrations by carly welcome thank you
so much
for having me what a beautiful setup
here i want to talk more about how you
create these beautiful beautiful
balloon arches and just everything you
can imagine but tell us a little bit
about your business and how how your
business came to be so i started this
business because of my love for making
all of life's events huge so i just
started with my kids making their
parties bigger and bigger and i remember
about 10 years ago telling one of my
friends if i could do this
professionally this would be a dream
come true
look at you now you're really creating
some great great uh things that kick
your party up a notch any celebration
whether it's a party or a baby shower or
a graduation right you do it all yeah
balloons are so much bigger than
birthdays and that's something i always
try and tell my clients they just we can
add greenery which totally elevates and
adds a different element to your event
less cheesy more formal
there's so many different times that it
can be used now i know so a lot of times
people will get a little nervous around
balloons because they're afraid of them
popping around there but you have a
different technique and i want you to
kind of show us how you do it so people
don't have to be worried about that yes
so balloon phobia is actually a super
real thing it is yeah i get nervous too
i'll have people contact me and say i
really want a balloon arch but i'm
scared to death of them popping so i
wanted to show you how we do it so they
don't pop okay so when you um inflate a
balloon like a helium balloon we're all
used to that light bulb shape that has
like the little um i'll show you
[Applause]
see how this has got the little bulb at
the bottom whenever you go to a party
store and you get helium they inflate it
like this and this is why we're all
traumatized of walking out to the car
and half of them popping so what we do
in our business is we
way under inflate them to about this
size so these balloons are the same size
as the ones that are big from the party
store but we under inflate them we even
under inflate our great big huge ones so
i mean feel that
it doesn't feel like it's on the verge
of pop yeah they're kind of mushy yeah
you can manipulate them a lot without
them popping so so you can still like
can we try with one of these big ones oh
yeah
these uh that was really cool how do you
do that so you push down on this pink
one
okay
now that's that's under inflated still
still really under inflated still mushy
it's not going to pop and that's why you
can make these beautiful creations how
do people get in touch with you if they
want to elevate their celebration so um
we take all of our orders through email
so email us at celebrations by carly
k-a-r-l-y
gmail.com and we can figure out exactly
what you need wow it just looks amazing
make sure if you didn't get that address
you can check out our website
eightnewsnow.com we'll have all the
information for you there and right now
we'll send it over to you jillian